In today's video
We are working with Patrick Adair Designs to make some amazing ring stock using melted bullet shells real meteorite and titanium
Hey guys today we are here with Patrick from Patrick Adair designs Patrick. What does your company do so I'm a ring maker?
I love making rings and I have a YouTube channel where I show you guys how I make them so I just make a bunch
of them do a bunch of different designs
and one of my favorite materials to work with is meteorite And you can see I have a  big slab of it here
It's just really cool because it has a lot of interesting patterns to it
But I get a lot of scrap that there's nothing really to do with it
So you can see we've got these shavings here as well as just those remnants there. So this is meteorite
Yes, and this is meteorite. Yeah, like meteorite that fell out of the sky and crashed into the earth. Yeah, that is super cool
Yeah these crash up in the Arctic Circle and they go out with metal detectors
And they have to find them send them over to the u.s
Cut them up with a bandsaw and this slab will get sent to me make ring blanks and then make rings from them
And what's this here? Is this so, this is titanium
So we've got titanium as well. I also thought it would be a cool idea to work with. very neat. Here's what we're going to try
We're going to take the meteorite shavings and the brass we got from melting down the bullets and we're going to cast them together
Later, we'll try to machine the ingot into a ring. We've got a bunch of these bullet casings
That's our source of brass. We need to melt those down in the furnace. So let's do that
and then while things are melting we can make a couple of
molds that we can put our meteorite pieces down into and then after that's in there pour the molten brass on top of it should
That work you think yeah, let's give it a shot
Oh that's like an oven in there
Alright we've got our brass shells in the cup we're gonna melt those down once that's melted down
We should be able to pour it into the meteorite. I think well that's melting we should get our molds ready
Meteorite shavings so that everything just ready to go as soon as that's nice and liquid. awesome
I had a couple different ideas of how we can try casting this and I admit that I have not done this a lot before
But you brought us these nice aluminum tubes
Which hopefully should give us a nice clean
Cast but aluminum has a lower melting point than brass and I don't want to melt the tube as we pour it in
So we've also got some sand and here's my thought we can tape the tube
Press it down somewhat into the sand and then build a bunch of sand up around the sides that
might act as a heat sink so that we can cast directly into the tube and not have it melts or
Deform too badly and then we should get a nice cylinder of our poor perfect
Yeah, and then I also have some of this silica firebrick and this is extremely heat resistant and somewhat porous
So I was thinking we might be able to drill a hole down into the fire rig and cast directly in it
Then once the casting cools down we can just break the fire break apart and reveal the casting inside
How do those sounds sounds great let's try it. Now. This is an experiment. We're hoping it will work
I don't know for sure a lot of this is an experiment
Have you ever tried embedding meteorite shavings in a metal before? I certainly have not so this all right
is gonna get crazy? How big of a casting do you think we should do in each of these?
well
I think
what we should do because it's nice because I have a lathe and what that does it crabs onto material then I spin it and
I'm able to cut some ring shape into it. So I need a little bit of excess space for that
so I think that the plan should be this will put about an inch or two of
meteorite shavings down in the bottom of each of them and
Then we'll fill it up with brass and we'll go a little bit past that and that excess material
That'll be for me to grab on to you'll end up with about a 3 maybe 4 inch long rod at the end
Okay
So this tube probably about the right size and then this one we could either cut short or we can just press it down farther
Into the sand either works. I guess let's figure out how many castings
I think our brass is ready to be poured. So at this point, what do you think?
Should we start taking our shavings and putting them into our two little tubes here?
Yeah, let's try sprinkling some of these in wonderful. We probably don't want too much of it
But we want enough that it will definitely be visible inside the ring. Yeah, that's the goal
Oh boy, there we go. All right here goes
Well, we definitely got it poured down in there now
We just kind of have to wait for it to cool down so we can see how well it did
Yeah, hopefully it got in with all those little meteorite pieces
We still have some brass that's molten, but we don't have enough for a whole second core
So let's just melt a little bit more.
Uh oh
So some meteorite definitely did get stuck in the brass
This magnet is very attracted to all the meteorites since it's made of iron and nickel but it can't pull it out
So we got a little bit of it. The question is how much let this cool off
So some things there worked well and some things did not
We didn't get the brass to float through the meteorite shavings and I think that's because they were too dense
So for this time around we're gonna try it with some titanium. We'll also try it again with some meteorite
We'll do a couple different techniques to try to do that
But for this titanium one, we're just gonna try to put them in there pretty loosely
So we'll just have a lot less density of the shavings themselves
I'm also very interested about the fact that our brass looks a lot more like copper at this point .wonder if it's
uh
Copper colored all the way through. we can sand away
True we should maybe grab a file
And start wearing this down, see if we've got some nice meteorite in there
We might still be able to get a ring out of this yeah
Well, I think we've got good brass I'm just not so sure about the meteorite
Maybe we can try like pouring some brass and then putting some more shavings on top
So yeah, yeah kind of layering it maybe that'll work
The brass is poured into our titaniun
Oh boy that I like how that slides out kind of think it shrinks when it cools that that's probably it. Ooh
It looks like we got our brass all the way down to the bottom on this one. It's not
a super
Smoothbore since we did for it in the three layers. You can definitely see those layers
But the titanium is definitely in there. Yeah. Hopefully we can cut away through that
It's just really not even very warm anymore. So
Yeah, I bet you can get some good stuff now, we don't really have the equipment here
To show what's on the inside of this but you have the equipment you can cut this open and see what it looks like
Right. Yes, we'll be taking a look at that
Crease here
Very cool. Well, let's try a couple more
I think this method worked better than just pouring it down on top of the meteorite shavings
so let's try the same thing with the
Meteorite in and then a little bit of brass and more meteorite and more brass in that area
See if we can get this same result. Yeah with the meteorite
I think we might want to try a combo even two titanium and meteorite
That might make for a Nice combination. Alright, let's try this
So let's get a little bits of titanium and meteorite shavings all ready to go and try this same method again. Alright
the titanium
Really holds itself together and makes much longer strands than the meteorite. It seems yeah, the meteorite kind of fragments. It's a lot more fragile
almost like metal prepared by outer space isn't quite as refined as metal prepared by people on earth interesting is that a diss on aliens
Suckers aliens got nothing on earth
Now we also have the other mold carved into our brick what do we want to do in that one?
Let's do make this one a kind of a combo. Okay
That go let go okay, you can just come out too
Perfect, thank you. You ready? Yep
here goes pour
this layer done
And that's that's cooled down
Whoo. Well, that's quite a bit more brass in those ones than we had before
Yeah, I think these will make some good castings Oh interesting the water seeps into the firebrick
You can see steam is actually just coming right out the side of the brick now
There it is
look at that the layers like really bonded in this one, yeah
All right. This one's maybe not quite as clean, but I still think we got some
Metal jam and you can see there's the big piece of meteorite right there sort of sticking out on the side
Okay, and you know, you're the one who's got the tools who's gonna be able to figure out if this will work?
Yeah, we'll have to see I have no idea Patrick. We got some interesting results. How do you feel about this?
I mean, I think we're gonna be able to make this do it was quite a bit of a challenge
We had a lot of problems with the materials not sticking together the layers being difficult
But I think in the end, I think we'll be able to get a ring out of these
All right
So this was our first one we tried just pouring all the brass down on top of the meteorite
Shavings and it wasn't really able to get past the meteorite shavings. those ended up just sitting on the bottom of it with no
Brass around them. We then tried moving on to using titanium and for this instead of just pouring it down on top
We had loosely sprinkled titanium. We poured some brass on sprinkled some more titanium more brass more titanium final layer of brass
So for this one, I think we got some good layers of titanium sandwiched into the brass
It looks like it's quite well bonded together. So this one will probably, will work out pretty well. Yeah, I think so
Once we just get past those rough edges. We've got on the outside
This is the one that was inside our fire brick
We had some big old chunks of meteorite in there as well as lots of shavings. There are a few different layers of pores
So I bet there's some good embedding going on here. And then this last one here this tall one. This one looks pretty good
I think we've got four layers of brass and we had meteorite shavings with titanium shavings mixed together all through
What's it gonna take to find out what's inside these things?
so I think what we're gonna want to do is just grind into them a little bit see what we've got going make sure that
We don't have any separation of the layers
We do on the edges of course, but I think once we grind into it a little bit
We should be able to see where it fuses together and once we get it
kind of shaved down and know what we're
working with that's when I'll put it in my lathe will just be able to work with it and trim it away and now we're
Left with the ring shape so it could be really interesting to see how this goes
Where is gonna be the best place to see the process of making?
these so I'm actually going to be making a ring from these and then be posting that to my youtube channel and that's what my
Channel is I just make a bunch of differing set of a bunch of cool different exotic materials
So I think this is gonna be a really interesting one this ring here. What is this one? This is pretty cool
so this is actually a limited edition king of random ring that we're going to do it is carbon fiber and it's infused with
Titanium so it's a really interesting material that's on the outside
And then the resin on the inside that is a glow resin and it's just in that king of random yellow
This is a prototype
That's just a little bit more green, but both the interior plastic and the color that it glows in the dark will be yellow
Look for those on his website Patrick Adair designs. The link is in the description below
Guys, it's not all if you want to see Patrick's video of turning this brass ingot into an amazing ring
just click the box up at the top if you want to get a meteorite or carbon fiber glow ring of your very own just
Check the link in the description below hit this bomb to become a subscriber to the channel
So you never miss out on a video. Don't forget to ring that Bell and we'll see you the next one. Talk to you then